latavius Murray joining us here on the
Rich Eisen show how are you latavius
rich how you doing how openly are you
talking about playing the Super Bowl in
your own building um honestly we we know
that it's never been done before I think
if you look at going into this all
season and everything like that that was
one of the things you know we we looked
at it was like man how cool how cool
would that be but of course in offseason
you know it's so far away is so much
more that needs to be done you know at
that point and then now here we are in
the in the you know in the heat of it
but knowing now more importantly is
about taking care of each week and so
you know again we feel that that's so
far away right now when you just talk
about each each week we have the kind of
battle to get to that point yes and
you've got a game against the Green Bay
Packers team that may or may not be
eliminated by the time that you take the
field with them and that is directly in
front of you but in terms of the the
journey here how is Mike Zimmer
approaching the possibility of what
obviously staring everybody in the face
right now um I want think coaches don't
you know kept us in check I think he
kept us focused on you know really to
what the first goal was and you know
that's been any you know I when I was
four years in Oakland and here winning
the division championship is you know
that's that's the first goal that a team
has and it's been my first you know that
we clinched yesterday so you know to
take care of that you know it's a start
you know to get into the tournament and
then now now it's about seeding and all
those things to try and again set
yourself up to be able to play for you
know play in front of this home crowd
for sure latavius Maori joining me here
on the Rich Eisen show and from your
position from how you have seen it how
his Case Keenum handled taking the reins
of this job and with Teddy Bridgewater
returning and everybody certainly in the
national media supposing it was just
going to be his job eventually how has
he handled all of this well I think you
know I think Teddy Teddy the pro and
you know I know obviously he wants to
you know he wants to be back on the
field it's been so long for him and so
that's why yesterday is such an
emotional moment and I think everybody
knew that some case you know everyone so
but but Teddy's been handling it well
you know takes cases been playing it
really good and and so you know I think
Teddy has just been patient and just
been you know getting better getting
back into it you know being out there in
practice again it's been over a year so
you know Teddy had the right attitude
that approach and what do you say to
those that say yeah this is a nice story
that's what's happening in Minnesota
because you know that what that's
infused with he yeah
I mean honestly man we like we can't get
caught up in to whether they believe in
us or not who believes in us what
matters is in that locker room at the
end of the day you know regardless
because win or lose you know that those
are the people you gotta you know turn
to you know when it comes down to that
and so I think we've we've done a good
job of that this year people going down
people need to step up and I still find
a ways to win and come together as a
team and so that's what that's what's
most important and it still will be
going forward but savingsmart Marie
joining me here on the Rich Eisen show
let's talk about your journey your path
why did you in open part ways from your
presume I mean to be honest I you know I
couldn't tell you this it was uh money I
couldn't tell you with whether or not
they felt I was you know the guy going
forward um you know III don't know you
know the conversations really never came
to that once I had the opportunity to
hit the market you know at that point it
was about what was best for me and so uh
and so you know I found a great place
here in Minnesota well in terms of that
do you think that they they had any
inkling that maybe Marshawn Lynch was
thinking of coming back do you think
that that was in the ether when you and
they were talking to each other I'm not
sure honestly I I wouldn't know
you know and if so you know it wasn't
wasn't communicating with me but I I'm
not sure at all I guess at that point I
really didn't I really didn't care I had
I just care that I was in a good
situation and I could you know have an
opportunity to you know better myself
better my family and play and win at the
end of the day we were winning and open
but I mean look at the season we're
having right now it's been special and
we're winning so and then one last one
because I know it's not your team
anymore okay and I know you're focused
on your current team so I have to infuse
my my my question with that caveat but
what do you think is is wrong with the
Raiders offense this year latavius I
mean you you know what it looks like
when it's humming you were part of that
last year what do you think ills that
offense this year you know I I'm not
sure honestly uh you know being there
over last year and you know we just you
know I just thought we just had to go
and find a way to win and you know again
I think I also you know the offense was
on fire and so I think that identity on
often maybe possibly I'm not sure but I
know they have you know all the weapons
for sure and so and then those guys are
you know close friends of my good
friends of mine from four years and so
um you know I hope they'd you know
figure it out and listen number success
yeah cuz I you know I mean look I I saw
from you latavius okay I saw when you
got out there in 2014 for a couple of
cups of coffee I could see that you had
some ability I even picked you up in
fantasy and still kicking myself that
day that I didn't have the cojones to
start you that night that you torch the
Chiefs on that Thursday night on NFL
Network and now you're so silly again I
think a lot of people kick their self
that nervous
I mean man you just just I mean it just
came out of nowhere
although UCF isn't nowhere anymore
absolutely there we go in honor in all
honesty here okay
I mean seriously cuz I you know I'm I'm
blinded by amazing blue blinders when I
talk about my alma mater if we put
Central Florida in an eight team playoff
and sent them to Clemson in a
first-round game what would happen let's
save this man you know I mean like you
say you sometimes you get the blinders
on but what I will say it will come down
to defense and who can stop who we have
the number one scoring offerings in the
country and so you know you know and and
I know Clinton's defenses is really
really good so I think it will come down
really to who can stop who I'm I'm gonna
have to say yeah just because those are
my voice um and and I think this season
it's been special I think it's gonna
finish special you know I could cause
you know he he came in and did some
tremendous things for this program and
and I just want to wish him the best
yeah now he's going back to Nebraska so
you really think UCF wins and advances
in Clemson latavius martin i do i
believe that okay
and these these griffin brothers are no
joke right you know one is not locking
things down in in Seattle right now in
the secondary and you know she cam what
he's doing right now do you know him do
you know these kids I do I do personally
yes I do okay um he's special I think
you know I think we and he can play you
know I think a lot of people look look
at his you know his situation and what
he's playing you know with but he's a
football player and he's a special
player and I think a lot of times you
people may get sidetracked from that but
he's a special players brother special
player and I think I think he's going to
do good things at the next level yeah I
can't wait to see with him at the
combine this year and beyond last one
my compadre uh Chris Brockman is a
Syracuse Orangemen or Syracuse Orange do
you want to do you want to ask him what
the obvious question here is yeah I see
you got the three one five phone number
I saw you at the final four a couple
years ago what is it gonna take for the
orange to get it turned around up there
all right dude you watch the game the
other night or the other day the
basketball game yeah but I'm talking
about football at Avis Oh mother I
thought the obvious question would be
why don't you go there interval so my
group turkey fan I mean you know Marvin
Harrison Donovan McNabb I mean you know
I grew up watching those guys and so I'm
you know cute that hard for her but when
when as I got older and I realized man I
had to get away I had to you know I had
to kind of start from fresh
get away from my familiar surroundings
you know and go into a new situation and
it was a great decision for me you know
I can't lie I grew up I matured it was
really what I needed but I always had a
love for cues know what they need to
turn the program around I you know I
just I think it's really tough you know
recruiting you know especially in the
north and you know they haven't had you
know the seasons that you know
Commission has had you know in the past
and so I think I think that's the
toughest thing man it's getting people
to believe getting people to want to be
a part of that tradition in the past and
getting guys to come out my thing that's
what it's gonna take
last one for you latavius Murray the
toughest defense you've seen and faced
this year is you know I'm gonna have to
say Carolina's force us to turn the ball
over a few times Benji I know I didn't
do squat so you know I gave it to him I
had to give it to mr. latavius thanks to
the time we'll chat with you down the
road okay Thank You Man
you bet that's latavius Murray at
latavius M on Twitter the Rich Eisen
show weakness
at noon eastern on audience